I'm sure you're all aware of the Coco
Chanel rule before you leave the house
you take one thing off the Ken rule is
you put three things on
[Music]
hi I'm Ryan Gosling if you're a Ken or
you're Ken curious or you're just
confused like I was you're in my top 10
Ken centrals to help you tap into your
kennergy
[Music]
headband
preferably lightning the headband is
important for Form and Function it
differentiates between good can and bad
can when you put it on it sends a clear
signal that it's go time but it's
essential that someone see you put it on
and preferably they see you put it on
from behind too this motion is important
you can also achieve this with a ball
cap you sort of start brim first eyes
cast and Shadow mysterious and then you
pick the moment and when it is go time
you reverse it now you're a loose cannon
ready to fire
sunglasses Ken's got to have at least
two pairs at all times you want the
first pair to be something that Barbie
would also wear she needs them for
whatever reason you have them at the
ready dark ones are great because they
can hide your sadness
you never want to risk bumming Barbie
out that's also why you have a second
pair Nat or mirrored so you can reflect
Barbie's greatness
because that's really your job you know
and she can use them to put on lipstick
while you hide your sadness so
two pairs of sunglasses
clutch
[Applause]
can in a box this is to remind you of
the box that you came in and the box
that the world will happily put you back
in if you don't count as hard as you can
every day
pretty outfit and just a reminder of
what you do if you forget he does Beach
watches generally the watch is a symbol
that you're busy and you have important
things to do and cool places to be when
you're a Ken you have none of those
things so cool so it's even more
important for you to appear that you do
I'm sure you're all aware of the Coco
Chanel rule before you leave the house
you take one thing off the Ken rule is
you put three things on
this I use for real world time
this is Barbie land time
and then I have this one because it
tracks the moon's phases so you can keep
track of the morning waves
[Music]
foreign
books are important unfortunately I just
have book but if you had more than one
you would have books books are better
preferably ones about horses
what can I say books make people think
that you have interests and Ken's number
one personality trait is just to look
interested in things not be interesting
don't make that mistake
okay that is a slippery slope just look
interested and books are great for that
because you can open them at any time at
any time you can just
[Music]
and look interested
interesting
thanks Mike Ken
okay surfboard and let me just start
this off by saying my Ken's job is Beach
I'm not surf Ken I'm Beach Ken and I'm
not claiming to be a surf cam so I don't
want any surfkins kind of
trolling me in the comment section okay
I'm not claiming to have any of this
sort of
spirituality that comes with surfing any
of that Insight I'm just using it for
scale because when you're a human sized
kin that's very important and so you
need a human size surfboard to
communicate that scale and you can hold
it and I've also found that you can also
lean
[Music]
rollerblades this is pretty
self-explanatory my Ken's Barbie likes
to rollerblade so he literally goes
nowhere without them did you bring your
rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
can underwear
look it's just important to have your
name written on your underwear for lots
of reasons I'm sure your mother's told
you that but most importantly it keeps
your name in the mix if you wear them
high it just keeps your name out there
it's easy to get lost in the shuffle and
it's also good because then if Barbie
ever says hey is that Ken written on
your underwear you can say
underwear
and that's all you want you just want to
share a moment with Barbie
a foam ink
if you can't Define Yourself by your
thoughts or experiences or
accomplishments
the filming can do a lot of the heavy
lifting for you you don't need any of
that because you're the Canon the foam
Inc
oh I'm happy did you know thank you for
noticing that it's a horse line
the Ken fanny pack
cool thing about this is that you can
have your name written on it in
Metallica font
what's even cooler about this is that
you can have Barbie's Essentials inside
of one of your Essentials I think it's
good to have a pink mic on hand you want
to toast Barbie accomplishments of which
there are many all the time every good
Barbie hype man has the pink mic you
know a hanky just in case she breaks a
sweat
I've never seen that happen you prepare
for the worst and you hope for the best
and then
you know you kind of have like a
statement necklace
you know who knows maybe one day you'll
get the baddest Barbie in the game to
wear your chain
so that's my top 10 Ken Essentials just
remember that
behind every great Barbie there's a Ken
it's totally fine with that hopefully
he's right behind her in case she needs
anything because she deserves it because
she's Barbie and he's
totally fine with that
forever
[Music]